kim Kardashian je vous le dis c'est tout
ce que je vais et Mathieu justement
pourquoi elle a été Harvard c'est
justement parce qu'elle pèse des
milliards
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi j'ai Justin Bieber avant dans tous
les droits de son catalogue musical donc
il a vendu son catalogue 200 millions de
dollars donc ça ne lui appartient plus à
actuellement d'autres l'avaient fait un
Bob Dylan Bruce sprinting pardon Shakira
fifty cent mais souvent sur les gens qui
sont plus en fin de carrière et le
répertoire comprend 290 titres séparents
qu'il faut que je vous dise et ça a été
démenti derrière c'est que en réalité
selon mes sources selon les tourneurs
que j'appelle il est en train de se
séparer de sa meuf et il a besoin mais
comme il y a quelques années il avait
rencontré Dieu je suis pas sûr vous
souvenez la main de Dieu me guide 2018
il m'a dit qu'il fallait l'aimer donc
quand on relève son mec fait un contrat
de mariage mais non Dieu m'a dit que
ouais mais fais un con il l'a pas fait
donc actuellement il passe 450 millions
d'euros et si divorce si on doit 225
millions à sa copine qui elle n'a jamais
rien fait à part un film donc ce qui
fait c'est qu'il est en train de vendre
son catalogue 200 millions avant divorce
et quand il divorcera il aura plus 450
millions d'euros de capital mais plus
que 200 ou 250 à partager avec sa femme
et là où c'est drôle effectivement c'est
que
idemment qui sont en train de se séparer
un couple qui démon qu'il est en train
de se séparer c'est pas un couple qui
est en train de se barrer une liaison
non ils se sont postés tous les deux en
train de fêter la vente du catalogue ils
ont fait une grande fête etc moi je
pense plutôt que il y aurait sûrement un
futur scandale qui va éclater donc il la
connaissance et qui impacterait la vente
de ses musiques etc et qui préfèrent
s'en débarrasser s'en débarrasser avant
que le scandale
dans son cas ça ferait monter encore
plus
kim Kardashian prof à Harvard choqué pas
choqué elle a donné la cour de commerce
de deux heures aux étudiants notamment
grâce à sa marque de sous-vêtements le
but était de savoir plus sur sa marque
également comment gagner de l'argent
comment elle a fait puisque aujourd'hui
elle gagne beaucoup beaucoup d'argent ça
marque estimée à 3,2 milliards elle a
atteint le statut de milliardaire avec
une fortune estimée en 2022 à 1,8
milliards de dollars moyennement choqué
mais c'est vrai que si je mettais mon
enfant à part c'est pas pour voir une
nana débouler qui a fait fortune
regarde la photo tu vois bien qu'il
n'est pas venu parler économie voilà
tout le monde sait qu'elle est
entrepreneuse je suis pas choqué parce
que je serai choqué qu'une école de
commerce de ce niveau là parle pas du
commerce de l'influence pardon et du
digital et invite pas des gens qui
savent parler parce que là-dessus donc
je suis pas choqué que l'école une école
de commerce invite une laque en fait du
commerce voilà tout simplement arrêter
parce que vous aimez ça dans la tête et
mon père aussi s'il me regarde arrêtez
pas te penser que si tu gagnes 5000 tu
es bien mais le mec qui gagne 10000 et
le mieux que toi le gars des 15 minutes
que l'argent est une valeur alors moi je
veux dire quelque chose d'accord je vous
dis quelque chose j'ai arrêté moi kim
Kardashian je vous le dis c'est tout ce
que je vais la vulgarité tout elle
serait allée dans une école de commerce
lambdaq 800 à Paris je m'en tape elle a
été dans l'institution mondiale qui
porte des plus grands avocats qui
forment Bill Gates qui forment les plus
grand c'est c'est HBs Mathieu justement
pourquoi elle a été à revoir c'est
justement parce qu'elle pèse des
milliards
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais bien essayer de faire du buzz
négatif j'aime bien gagner de l'argent
depuis mon chou j'ai pas le temps de te
répondre mais déjà gagné de l'argent
gagner de l'argent ce n'est pas un
objectif accomplis toi fais quelque
chose de ta vie mais une de toi
assurance travail
peut-on s'asseoir sur ces beaux
principes pour une grosse somme d'argent
c'est en tout cas ce qu'aurait fait la
super star Beyoncé selon la communauté
LGBT en se produisant à Dubaï lors de
l'ouverture d'un hôtel de luxe
[Musique]
[Rires]
pour la coquette somme de 24 millions
d'euros
ça c'est clair devenu ces dernières
années l'une des icônes du mouvement
LGBT la diva a donc suscité la polémique
en chantant dans les miracles qui n'est
pas franchement connu pour être une
paire de tolérance puisque
l'homosexualité il est interdite par
exemple en fait si s'avère que son
dernier album qui s'appelle Renaissance
qui est sorti à pas très longtemps elle
l'avait dédié à son oncle Johnny qui est
décédé des suites du VIH qui était gay
et elle avait décidé de faire un album
et quand elle s'est rendue à ce concert
là pour lequel on rappelle quand même
touché 24 millions de dollars et pour
lequel on rappelle aussi que
l'homosexualité là-bas est un crime
passible de 10 ans de prison voilà et là
elle n'a pas du tout chanté cet album là
elle va chanter les chansons pour
lesquelles on la connaît et elle a
décidé de ne pas chanter ses chansons là
qui était en soutien LGBT donc tous les
fans étaient très très en colère n'ont
pas compris à quoi elle jouait mais moi
si je peux me donner mon avis je suis
persuadé les 24 millions de dollars pour
la recherche pour que le VIH je suis sûr
et certaine qu'elle va le faire
parce que Olympe effectivement tu as
fait The Voice et vraiment tu as déclaré
après coup tout ce que tu avais vécu ce
qu'on t'a dit là-bas grosso modo et
pourtant à l'époque tu faisais 68 kg tu
dis après l'émission bah en fait on est
parti en tournée avec Louane avec plein
de monde et on a appris tous un peu de
poids je pense que je devais faire aller
74 75 kg à l'époque et là en fait mon
équipe artistique m'a dit ben on peut
plus te mettre en télé tu es trop gros
on est obligé de te cacher derrière un
piano mais moi c'est dans The Voice que
j'ai découvert que j'étais grosse en
fait c'est pas que ça m'a fait mal c'est
que ça m'a surpris je me suis dit que
les réseaux sociaux tout le monde a
accès à ce qu'on dit quand on a un
compte public etc et je me suis dit
quelle est cette personne qui se fout la
honte de dire un truc comme ça le
premier commentaire je passe à la télé
le premier commentaire Twitter c'est
quand je te vois j'ai envie de vomir ce
à quoi j'ai répondu
j'ai fait The Voice The Voice j'ai fait
The Voice parce que ça s'appelait pas
the body the Voice
que une voie raison et en fait moi ce
que j'ai gardé de c'est pas mon contrat
de disque que j'ai eu après c'est pas
mon manager eux ils sont taillés mais il
y a des gens qui me suivent encore
aujourd'hui qui soutiennent mon travail
qui achète mes singles qui m'écoutent
toujours et qui m'ont découvert dans The
Voice le seul truc qui est resté
justement c'est le public parce que le
public est beaucoup moins con qu'on ne
le pense et je pense qu'il faudrait
qu'on lui donne
[Applaudissements]
c'est une danseuse juste les salaires
alors les salaires c'est vrai qu'ils ont
grossièrement baissé après il faut dire
que l'émission ce que tu veux dire il y
a des gens qui gagnent 1000 balles mais
vas-y non mais évidemment ça reste des
salaires exorbitants voilà quelqu'un
lambda mais c'est vrai que Zazie qui
touchait entre 800 et 900000 euros quand
elle était là dans les premières saisons
elle va passer aux alentours de 50600000
ensuite Amel Bent elle est au alentours
de 300000 elle va passer à 200000 et
vient nez et Bigflo et Oli ils sont aux
alentours de 150000 c'est les plus
faibles cachés historiques de l'histoire
de The Voice mais en même temps le coup
de production à baisser c'était environ
un million d'euros par prime dans les
premières saisons et où on est
aujourd'hui on est dans aux alentours
pardonne de 750 000 euros merci